boxing to me is like a way of motivation
and getting out the hood being a kid
growing up in Chicago and you see a lot
of drug dealing gang banging and
shootouts but we're in the city
Sean kids like this isn't just a bubble
in this out everything is like you got
how to believe that yourself that you
could see motive yes you could be better
than us this great big story is made
possible by the shy on Showtime
[Music]
[Applause]
my name is Sally Hazel Grove and I am
the founder and executive director of
restoring the path
crushers Club yet in 2000 I was living
in Chicago and I started studying gangs
and interviewing gang members and I
asked them in 2004 what's something that
would get you off the block and boxing
was their number one answer from hearing
their stories I started to formulate a
vision and in March of 2013 I opened
Crusher's Club questioners club is a
place where youth come as an alternative
to gangs and as a way to terminate off a
juvenile probation
[Music]
learn to wonder since opening our doors
we've seen over 500 youths they can let
down their guard they can be young men
they can empathize with each other they
can be funny I tell all of them it's
your job to save all the children I'm
here to empower you and for you to leave
because they are the changemakers
[Music]
I didn't have no easy experience being
in Chicago like when I was six I think
my daddy gets shot right in front I had
so many close friends took me in like
friends just in general that just
getting killed of non-violence after a
while like me death just became noon I
[Music]
started kind of first club when I was
nine years old ever since then I just
been boxing I had to look at the bigger
picture instead of just seeing the
streets and being enticed by what you
see a date because I see drug dealers
boosters people something we've he was
on crack all that stuff it's high school
dude it to be to be that type of person
but I don't know I'm bigger than the
street the boxing ring it was like
almost by my guidance I'm out there in
any time I had an issue any time I had a
problem in time I felt some type of way
soon as I step foot in crest school I
felt like I was on top
[Music]
[Music]
come on boyo run this way before you run
that way we've had a lot of success at
crushers I've seen young men that were
on the street Judy now come to me and
say I know what a game back and I put
down my gun
these are not hardened criminals and
we're gonna fight for them pretty much
to our dying breath
[Music]
look at all these pictures are you this
kid is like you're not just thinking
about yourself you're thinking about the
kids you use the kid you can still have
a kid life you still do the basic things
that any other kid and any other city
wanna do you feel that family Empire in
that family bad when you enter I know
what I'm doing I wouldn't be the same
person if it wasn't for crust club of
boxing I feel like this I mean like my
real beginning cuz I got way more to go
it's just like the tip of the iceberg